guys and girls that come together and
when they come in together now it's like
they're seeing it as a situation where
they're able to kind of just like
pretend that they're studying as well at
the same time and then at the same time
they can kind of chat to the girl that
they like as well which is on let's say
on the other side well I've seen quite a
lot of guys as well they would do this
where they'll actually go to lecture
Halls just to shut the goals why oh is
our youngsters afraid to go to the
parents for something that is halal and
then they have to resort to something
that is Haram but if you can't speak to
your own family about the decisions
you're making like you said and you've
got to feel comfortable and you haven't
got that relationship who do your time
to who what can you do so a lot of times
you're not even fond of like Mom and Dad
so Mom and Dad yeah let's say they did
install with values in them they're
getting attacked now from the school
system again attack from social media
they're getting attacked from you know
outside external influences so going
back to your point our sister inshallah
Zeus all of that kind of stuff they
can't they they hit you I would say in
year nine and year 10 when they start
rolling it up in front of you and it
hits you differently my own cousin
person Andy left his school at year
seven he went to an Islamic school they
were building something literally right
in front of him and his dad said no no
no I'm not sending my child there
anymore and he was in Islam in that case
it doesn't matter where you put your
child or where you go or where you are
in the world as an adult even not even
just as a child is what you have within
you within your heart within your head
isn't that what what you should be
taking with you and the other thing
people who you're surround with isn't it
parents responsibility at that age when
you're 13 14 to keep an eye out for who
you're hanging around
no
don't miss this amazing opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now
brothers and sisters and dear friends
hope you guys are well inshallah welcome
to another episode of The Bitter truth
show where we are trying to spit some
bitter trucia before I start I want to
praise Allah the most merciful the most
trust or Praises glory and gratitude
should belong to him and before we start
some disclaimers um I want to meet
because the last episode went on a bit
of a Mad one
um to be honest uh we and I just want to
make certain things clear
um I don't invite people here who I
agree with because if we if I had a
discussion here today and I said is
Islam the truth you would say yes yes
yes yes yes and obviously
um non-muslim sister here may Allah
bless her she's coming she's gonna have
amazing contributions inshallah but
nobody will talk about anything everyone
agrees I invite people here who I
disagree with yeah I don't care if it's
a feminist who beats her husband up
um I don't care if it's um
whoever it may be I would invite them
here and I would challenge them I would
like a discussion I want to talk to them
I would like to understand them and I
would like to challenge their views so
just making that clear inshallah that
many people here might disagree with you
guys
especially you
yeah so yeah that's number one number
two a disclaimer for anyone that's
watching and saying you guys are free
mixing
um I would just say maybe you should go
study um I'll pay for your tuition fees
uh yeah personally I'll sponsor you a go
study and learn what free mixing is yeah
because what you're doing is you're
actually accusing us and these honorable
sisters that we are coming here to
intermingle yeah so that's a slander so
please go study your religion learn what
free mixing is learn the conditions of
it
um but anyways
okay I didn't know that if it's major
senior yeah okay okay
that's amazing yeah exactly free mixing
I'm not sure if it is but the point is
what you are accusing us of something we
are not doing anyways uh let's get to
the topic and shall give those we have
to give a lot disclaimer systems forgive
us here uh because we're dealing with um
some trolls so anyway so we've got some
brothers here and some sisters bless
them
um the topic here is some of them are
uni students I think most of them are
uni students the topic at hand today is
going to be
whichever will be interesting and by the
way this is sponsored by
um uni student match yes I've got it
right check them out brothers and
sisters inshallah if you want if you are
a uni student and you want to find
someone just like yourself and graduates
yeah yeah
um
tell him again so yeah uni students and
graduate students I've made it in a way
where essentially people who are
studying at University and people who
are essentially graduated as well so
both parties can essentially sign up
exactly there you go Brown sisters as
well check them out inshallah so today's
topic is going to be uni Fitness or
Fitness in uni
um I think we can start off with uh
firstly introducing our guests inshallah
let's start off with the sister sister
from your side and then intro just tell
us a bit about your name and what you do
what's that America my name is Asia
um
I don't know I'll studying chart okay
inshallah yeah may Allah bless you uh
Child Care childcare
my name is
um I do business management and I have
two of my own businesses
I'm Sasha
um I actually studied
paramedic science and
um I've left uni
myself as well I can remember the second
year I thought no it's a long thing
um so I left it so the sister Sasha is
actually non-muslim
um seek Hindu yeah yeah seek Hindu uh
we're open to all religions including
Islam so okay yeah but um I'm quite you
know educated in most religions so okay
yeah but quite accepting yeah okay it's
a pleasure to have you you're the first
non-muslim guest on the show I
appreciate it and we appreciate your
time and effort and I'm sure you're
gonna have amazing contributions to this
episode and brother I'm sorry
assalamualaikum my name is Adam
um I've actually graduated uni so I'm
doing I did accounting and finance and
now I'm working as an accountant yeah
I'm gonna have to come to you from
accounts um attachments after me yeah so
my name is Omar I finish uni I'm
studying
2018 to 2021 so the economics and yeah
I'm the founder of uni students match
the viewers out there my name is uh
Muhammad Osama and I'm currently a
paralegal I graduated my LLB law degree
last year and I'm currently doing the
sqe in Charlotte also a co-founder of
uni students match as well esteemed
brother martial and uh yeah so I came
today you know because it's a call to
action for our brothers and sisters out
there to tune into the bitter truth so
at the end of the day inshallah
bless you guys inshallah so we've got
business women and businessmen here also
we're introducing something a little a
little new which we're going to try out
we've got the uh
um those who are listening inshallah
guests who are on the sofa if they have
a question they'll put their hand up the
camera will go to them we're going to
test out see how it goes inshallah but
yeah let's open the discussion up
inshallah let's start with our own
relationships man that's a cliche you
know I'm kind of known for that as well
and not that I'm in a Haram Malaysia but
I refute them just to make some
clarification Yeah because sometimes
sometimes you know when I say I'm
involved in haramblesh they're like oh
yeah that sounded wrong brother yeah so
yeah yeah yeah
that's what they're always that's what
they always do to me so yeah so now talk
to me yeah okay I think uni is a hub for
these kind of things here
um so I would say personally
do you think people go to UNI because
sometimes you have people who are just
leaving the house yeah for example they
have to travel so they say they live in
London they're like I need to go study
in Manchester whatever it may be so it's
not going to escape for them yeah and
they're like no Mom and Dad or Marquis
Etc I've got my own accommodation
um does it open the doors to Fitness in
uni so who should I start with um so by
the way fit not yeah sorry forgive us
please remind me Fitness is like um
Temptation trials okay
um so things like for example hardship
it can be well it can be a blessing as
well but the word Fitness means like
it's it's a test to try it yeah yeah
so um yeah Haram relationship um do you
guys see this in the Unis yeah so
essentially it's become guys I need you
by the way Mike's please yeah close yeah
so it's become it's a situation at
University where
guys and girls that come together and
when they're coming together now it's
like
they're seeing it as a situation where
they're able to kind of just like attend
that they're studying as well at the
same time and then at the same time they
can kind of chat to the girl that they
like as well which is on let's say on
the other side so if she's on the other
side certain times you can be like okay
cool it's a big lecture hall I can go
and sit over there because you see in
lectures anyway you can pretty much say
anywhere you know what I'm saying so
then obviously when you when you sit
anyway you're able to kind of you know
communicate with whoever goes that you
essentially pretty much like 100 so a
lot of times guys and girls they will
kind of just do that at uniform what
I've seen as well and then situations
where guys and girls all for them anyway
but like I've seen quite a lot of guys
as well they'll do this where they'll
actually go to lecture Halls just to
check the girls you know what I'm saying
it's literally okay
100 nobody really like at mindset of
Union at that especially for guys in it
they're not really coming you know to be
listening to the lecture yeah for for
majority of people anyway they're coming
in there to to do a bad chitchat I'm
saying so then you know how that needs
to and then yeah do you guys get like
people in uni where they're like because
I went to London met here I was not a
Muslim then yeah and I was kind of
looking into it and and I would see like
to me like I don't know I can remember
back in Japanese like like obviously
you're doing some giant Stuff Etc but
thinking of it now then when I think of
it now as a Muslim then I'm like well
that was Peak actually because I can
remember there was one girl who would
literally like
um should be in a job
Etc and then like going club and you'll
be thinking wow but to me I was thinking
that's just no but think of it now
that's actually quite mad so I would see
people in her own relationships like
studying together like stuck together
like my mind's like you know like got
his handle and they're just you know
studying exactly there's no restrictions
on you know when it comes to allocated
seats and stuff like that everyone's
just basically able to mingle okay
you've got people get refuted brother oh
yeah okay
I'm so sorry I just needed to stop you
there okay I just feel like
most boys go to UNI for girls I see boys
on tick tock on live with hijabi girls
yeah just to go uni for girls like you
know you're a Muslim and you're doing
Haram but
you don't care like
do you not know Allah is looking down on
you he knows what you're doing what
you're saying what you're like
okay
no I'm good I'm good
sorry sorry it's no disrespect I just I
just pressed the problem
yeah I pressed the buzzer because uh I
feel like when you stated that people
don't care I feel like they do care it's
just that some I don't know they just
fall into that trap of seeing everyone
else doing the same thing you have to
have a really strong like mindset in
order to get out of that okay
you're only allowed to press it once so
I'm just just okay let me just
understand something
um you said Brothers gone can you just
say that again please
making videos of her job because like
they don't care I'm sorry you said they
do care but they don't okay so but but
okay okay okay
one second who's to blame like the
things we're talking about here these
these guys were making these tick tocks
um with these hijabi girls
um who's to blame so sister Sasha okay
so as you know I'm not Muslim so from
this is from me from just a religious
perspective uh I was brought up in the
hindusek family right but
um I've had influences from Islam from
Christianity from all sorts of religions
and I think it's not just one gender or
One race or anything to blame I think it
comes from both parties if you know it
takes two to mingle at the end of the
day so if you consider something Haram
for example relationships in uni for um
the topic that we're on
unfortunately there is not one party
that you can blame it's both to blame if
you're in a relationship there's both of
you not just one person right and it's
down to your own conscious effort
whether you choose to stay in that
relationship and carry on committing
that sin per se because it's Haram right
so
I would personally say it's you know
whoever's in the relationship both of
them together should be equally blamed
absolutely you know she finished that
one because she got 20 seconds left go
ahead you're finished okay so um I'd
literally just like to add to that so
when we look at it from a holistic point
of view and an approach now each other a
relationship or even marriage now for
example is a contractual obligation
between two people you can't have a
marriage with just one person for
example do you see what I'm saying
there's there's no like Independence to
marriage it's teamwork commitment and
communication lastly and I'd like to
really emphasize communication here
because I think that's the majority of
our young brothers and sisters are
falling into you know major major
difficulties and misinterpretations as
well because now
when it comes to communication a major
part of communication is being able to
kind of speak to your parents when
you're going through this a lot of
brothers and sisters they shock bro yeah
I'm going to be completely honest with
you they're scared of their parents and
why is that you know your parents need
to be your best friends they need to be
that shoulder to cry or they need to be
that person there for you to always come
to you know it's my nightshow that's a
very good point just just something you
mentioned sister Sasha just so you know
that in Islam Allah says in the Quran
that when it comes to you because
there's a there's a capital punishments
so for for a man and a woman who commits
uh sexual intercourse outside of
marriage uh there's a hundred lashes uh
in public yeah okay there's there's
stipulations to it so it's not like
Prophet so we need to go back to that
yeah exactly um yeah yeah you might get
arrested for that but so
um but it's not yet so and then for
adulterers for example there's capital
punishment which is
um so it's like in the Bible yes um you
get punished for adultery yes so you
know it's very similar because if you
read the Bible and Quran right they're
both um the interpretation is the same
even to the point the prophet so I do
understand you know
the punishments you've got to remember
as well in terms of religion you've got
to remember religion started thousands
of years ago when that it was acceptable
now it's open to interpretation right
but I think personally as long as you
have a you know heart of gold as long as
you're not you know hurting anyone else
so why should you know anybody else's
judgment in this day and age affect you
okay good there's three things you
mentioned I was just going to finish the
point which was the following that Allah
says the one who commits dinner be a man
or a woman you flog them both and don't
have pity on them so what you said about
it's two there's not one or the other
they're both to blame do you get it so
Allah and also for example you mentioned
about if they're not harming no one the
reason why Islam is so harsh and has
stipulated Capital punishments in
certain instances is because Islam is
there to protect communal rights an
individual who's going to drink alcohol
who says give me the rights so I can
drink alcohol that necessarily yes it's
Haram but what effects are you gonna
have on the community when you draw
having a car 100 miles an hour and you
hit seven people and kill them or number
two
um in America most and this is very
discussing actually ancestrous
relationship that happened and one of
the reasons alcohol so the thing is you
look at is a mother of all evil so in
this matter that's why Islam is so harsh
because it wants to deter people from
going down the route and now even I
think there was a study that showed in
in in London there are a million people
have STDs yeah so so even today some
somebody was asking me oh like is it
like can we ask people now to like do a
test and I was thinking does it come to
that so the question here is the
following you said something very
important yeah
um parents parents do not blame the
parents because why why is our
youngsters afraid to go to the parents
for something that is halal and then
they have to resort to something that is
Haram so if the parents are watching
this do you not think they play a
massive role in Beyond let's not totally
blame them because people like to blame
that yes because of my whatever it may
mean yeah you shouldn't commit Haram
regardless you can't blame under their
judgment Allah is not going to say oh it
was because okay it's not going to so
can we maybe blame their parents sister
and then everyone say no because no I
don't think something accountability is
key in this Dunya likes you have to take
responsibility for your actions 100
okay I think okay so you're saying the
parents
oh no I don't think the parents are to
blame I think at all I think
communication is key like um brother
Muhammad said not not necessarily reason
being now is because the parents need to
make that effort to connect with their
child the parents are doing a great
Injustice on the child if they aren't
taking those significant steps in better
understanding their child this is this
is an entity now that's come out of the
womb of a mother now so how can you tell
me you know that you feel closer to your
friends for example you feel closer to
people that aren't even your blood to
commit your parents it's mad yeah I
think I might be seeing it through like
a tunnel vision because like I have a
good relationship with my parents
obviously like I'm a very communication
is clear so maybe that's why I see it in
more of a bias and I would like to add
in our family generation obviously being
from India your parents right they get
arranged marriages in their time right
nowadays we are such a more successful
of depending on what kind of family you
come from you're more uh open to making
your own decisions to an extent but if
you can't speak to your own family about
the decisions you're making like you
said
and you don't feel comfortable and you
haven't got that relationship who do you
turn to who what what can you do like
who do you ask is this right is this
wrong if your own family are pushing you
away you know that's very interesting
you know sometimes I feel this is
something very crazy here sometimes I
feel like the non-muslims follow the
Sunnah more than more than us because
think about you bro these people bro
trust me you would have them going and
talking about everything bro but if
you've got so much salt the parents are
coming in
please forgive me I'm trying to you know
for educational purposes yeah yeah I'm
not trying to you know be a group but
you know they would give them here's a
protection yeah and I'm thinking yeah
and obviously that's a mad that's crazy
yeah but what I'm seeing is they are
open okay this is my boyfriend or this
is my girlfriend these are all harambers
but but the point the point is this the
fact that they can have that discussion
is the Sunnah I'm talking about yeah not
this disgusting things but the point is
that when when they can come and open up
and that's how it should be do you
understand it should be that you're
you're like why can't I've got
daughter's birth if my daughter came to
me and said I'm at Uni yeah and there is
a brother who proposed to me arguments
say oh for example
um there is a brother that I find that
liking to am I going to be like what how
could you feel like that was it but one
light I think it's dumb like anything is
dumb bro my daughter is a human being
she has emotions yeah why am I why am I
going to build it's gonna be like how
could you feel like this what are you
talking about brother she's a woman
she's if he's come to me I want to get
married I'll be so happy that she she's
coming to me and I'll say you know but
let me do some background checks on the
guy yeah yeah let me start electrocuting
him a bit and see what I want to see
what he's about yeah literally sometimes
you got electrocute the brothers or
sisters yeah because I know a brother
I'm a man I know a man I would want to
do some background research on the guy
see what he's about do my due diligence
see if he's praying if he's got if he's
got taqwa then I will go and say listen
this that's my duty comes to UNI she
came to me about you yeah I want to
arrange a Halal meeting for you guys to
get to know each other because I can
relate to that because I've got a
younger sister myself and when it comes
to the women folk now within your Family
Martial law like I've been blessed with
that ability to always be there for my
mother whether whether it comes to my
mother sometimes you know when you're
out with certain family members and
stuff as well and they cover they dress
modestly and stuff you do that extra to
help them out I've been in situations
bro where the wind bees blowing and
accidentally I'm not going to say who
the who the um aunties are who the
sisters or anything sometimes sometimes
something would slip out when it comes
to your hearing stuff yeah and the I
would say polite yeah I'd say auntie you
know um
it's um showing from the back of being
Shonda even do you see what I'm saying
and now when when it comes to the turbia
from your parents growing up in a
righteous Muslim household and stuff
they instill these values onto you
growing up basically so Masha Allah you
know that it's called Rita you know it's
called protective Genesee and I think
yes
so you know what isn't it we're in a
situation right now in the economy yeah
yeah that men and women are having to
work in it so they're not able to
essentially live on one essential income
so men men I work women out at work so
the man and the mom so both the mum and
the Dada well now if Mom and Dad are at
work now who's teaching the kids who's
teaching the kids the values a lot of
times and that's what you see a lot of
generation excellent after 2000. a lot
of these you know like my generation and
people who essentially you know younger
than me they haven't been taught these
values you know from from parents and I
haven't been instilled in them for
example let's say with a relationship
yeah first thing like if I was to have a
door for example I'll tell her first
thing is that you know as as value you
get value from being married you
understand you don't get value from
being in boyfriend girlfriend
relationship reason being is because
that's not essentially a commitment
Johnson marriage essentially from God's
eyes is a commitment it's essentially a
marriage contract and you're essentially
working hard both you're striving
towards God's path but you look what you
want to do is you want to get into that
boyfriend girlfriend relationships
there's no there's no signatures there's
no pen and paper there's no Mom and Dad
there's none of that and then you're not
expecting you know a good outcome from
them especially because you get good
outcomes something around relationships
especially when it doesn't work
especially especially with young men
okay like for example how would you guys
the point is this thought I can remember
like and this is the thing where a lot
of people don't understand is that at
the end of the day most of the times I
see sister stuff on when you get into
this around relationships and that's why
to be honest um I usually warn sisters
against men and some brothers will come
like yeah you know why so obsessed I'm
like listen I'm being real because at
the end of the day brother you can put
grow your beard
there is no his past is history you're
clean but the moment she her name is you
know I'm trying to say so that's why
subhanallah it's very and that's why in
Islam with the seven major sins yeah
there's there's more than that but the
prophet peace be upon him said and one
of them is that you slander a chased
woman it is severe yes you get 80 lashes
yeah but if somebody goes and says oh
yeah you see that yo yeah I saw her in
next man's car however you're done if
that if that is established you're
getting flogged in public but isn't I'm
sure slander and chatting
um bad on someone's name isn't that uh
Haram as well in itself there's
backbiting and there's um slander yeah
so backbiting is for example if I go
behind his back and go you know what
well this guy is a bit of a waste man
yeah but he's a beautiful woman if I
said that that's that's backbiting yeah
okay and if what I said is true that's
backbiting if what I said is a lie
that's slander so slander for example
it's it's if the person and you've
slandered if they don't forgive you
you're getting flogged yeah in Islam and
it's not you know Islamic country
um so the thing is here it's that young
girls don't understand but as men you
need to understand at a young age our
hormones are like like let me say
something it's Peak it's Peak and and
and and to a man he will say and do
whatever he wants he has to say to get
what he wants it's as simple as that
that's what it isn't obviously with the
media influence and then you know you've
got social media you got essentially
your school systems you've got all these
things in place right now where those
are all external so a lot of times
you're not even in front of like Mom and
Dad so Mom and Dad yeah let's say they
did instill with values in them they get
intact they're getting attacked now from
the school system yeah they're getting
attacked from social media they're
getting attacked from you know outside
external it influences and that going
back to my point being there's two
people to you know blame you can't just
blame the one person yeah yeah
um being like you know I mean chatting
on a girl's name but what about the guy
he's gone and didn't done whatever he
did whatever you know what I mean it's
more severe consequences for girls
you're getting devalued in the marriage
marketplace now if you girls don't know
what marriage Marketplace is you need to
study it because a lot of times guys
girls nowadays they've got no idea
Marketplace you need to understand what
you've what your values
that's true this terminology by the way
some people blame you oh look how you
play speaking red pill yeah okay
bro I get I see certain stuff brother
I'm trying to make a fact here it's
ready to use it that's not my problem
I'm trying to say what we're trying to
say is the repercussions for a woman is
more greater so as men when we come here
and start the bitter trick and I talk
about this stuff I'm here genuinely
looking out for you sisters but see me
as a brother that's a bit harsh no
problem you don't like me dislike me but
if you can take some things wrong but no
problem let me be the bad guy no problem
that was very bad he's horrible okay no
problem if there's some things that you
can take and Implement I'm not here I
see like every single one of you guys
like my own sister you know what I'm
trying to say and that's how it should
be so the thing is dude we're just
trying to say how is the ways of
maneuvering as a non-muslim I want to
come to sustain inshallah as well yeah
um as a non-muslim when you see Muslims
who are indulged in these Haram
relationships do you have a question
mark and be like they shouldn't be doing
that
it's a good question
um I've been taught not to judge right
but you do Ponder you know being Muslim
that what I see is people are very
religious people go to mosque they pray
five times a day you know that you do
the Ramadan eat all of that so then why
would you take the extra effort then to
commit Haram when you're wearing on a
carb your um your hijab and you know
you're so so say in this like very
religious family modest yeah yeah so uh
in trouble yeah yeah I'll stay on it
this is the finished partner
so like how are you gonna sit there in
the same breath and commit these sins
when you were there you know doing all
of this religious stuff does that not
just defeat the purpose in the first
place what it is is that now if you're
an individual that's grown up in a
country now where they've literally
flooding you now with Western ideologies
now so much so that even if I go back to
PK now for example Pakistan now yeah
I've been to the schools in Pakistan for
about a year so six to seven years old I
spent in Pakistan they were a lot more
Western than the UK I would say I would
even argue reason being yeah and there
would be times yeah where they would be
swinging happy birthday wallahi on the
Quran my mom will even verify this for
you Lord yeah bro there would be times
where I'd be crying my head off saying
that this is Haram what are you doing
now what are you doing why are they
banging out right now saying happy
birthday and stuff and the reason for
that brothers and sisters is it comes
from the tobia of the household but it's
like brother Alma said previously now
where these systems now that have been
put into place by the government next
one said obviously I can't talk on that
but now these systems that are there now
they tarnish the work of your father and
mother because they swim they've
invested years into this individual that
they've loved they've nurtured they
brought him up to be the best person he
could possibly be to be the best um what
mean that he could be that or even she
could be Insha'Allah and
um they put all of this they literally
poured it into this person now now
they're raising this child now he's
starting to come along and stuff now
he's going to school he's starting to
grow a bit more independent now all of a
sudden they're seeing things like
production videos all of this stuff now
when it comes to the education and stuff
and I think that hits a person in year
seven and eight so going back to your
point our sister inshallah Zeus all of
that kind of stuff they can they they
hit you I would say in year nine and
year 10 where they start rolling it up
in front of you and it hits you
differently my own cousin personally
left his school at year seven he went to
an Islamic school they were building
something literally right in front of
him and his dad said no no no I'm not
sending my child there anymore and it
was an Islamic school bro I don't want
to see what the school was I don't want
to say it was an Islamic school
quickly I want to say
okay that was happening and right in
front of your eyes in an Islamic school
right so in that case it doesn't matter
where you put your child or where you go
or where you are in the world as an
adult even not even just as a child is
what you have within you within your
heart within your head isn't that what
what you should be taking with you I
mean if they could be billing stuff in
an Islamic school that's just major
disrespectful I would never even think
of doing anything you know I mean even
today coming here I was like I don't
want to offend anyone you know what I
mean am I dressed appropriately am I you
know what I mean so I think that comes
down to one your parents because if you
have upper hand on your child all the
time and you put your foot down on them
all the single time because some parents
can be very strict yeah that will make
you sway yeah Society will make you sway
but if you've got a good upbringing if
you've got a strong household that will
help you stay in your you know Lane
basically yeah
and the other thing people who you
surround with isn't it parents
responsibility at that age when you're
13 14 to keep an eye out for who you're
hanging around with yeah whoever you're
hanging around with is you know that's
what you're betrayed as you know what I
mean you are the product the production
Society you know I mean who you surround
yourself with what you surround yourself
with it doesn't matter where you are and
then tell me who your friends and I'll
tell you like myself do you ever see
Haram relationships uni okay do you ever
see this stuff sister and then be like
like I don't know like do you ever come
across it and and one thing that when
you touch up on yeah because a couple of
years ago when I first came to Islam I
used to have these haramulation cards
here it was pink and blue okay so I
would go to scissors and say you know
you deserve more than that I know said
to the brothers one you know if that was
your sister so I would give these cards
out yeah and to be honest one like I was
thinking to myself some people like oh
do you not feel shy or awkward I said
bro just think about it that's a deep
statement you know they are not
true the point is this though this is
where Allah says in the Quran let their
rise amongst you a group of people who
will enjoy good and forbid evil yeah
okay and for that you don't need to be
sinless people come and say oh yeah but
what about your sins
but where in the Ayah does it say that
only sinless people have to enjoy good
and forbid evil so the reason if we
don't do this this is why the other
nations fell into what they fell into
because they stopped enjoying and gonna
forbidden evil bro they just said you
know what let them do what they're doing
I'm chilling again who cares ever I just
care about myself okay and there was
corruption in the land and the prophet
peace be upon him said
he said that Allah said that you would
either enjoy good or forbid evil or that
Allah will send the Calamity that even
if you crochet we rejected from you so
the point we're saying is the is what
that we have to do our bit they are not
shy to do that and I'm going to be shy
to approach them to give them some Nasir
so the thing is obviously we have to be
balanced because I was in King's cross
yeah yeah I was in I was in Kings Cross
a couple of days ago yeah and I happened
to see a brother kissing the cheek of
some hijabi girl and I thought to myself
they're my Republic yeah so I just left
that so let's just don't go extreme uh
finding anybody and everybody
um obviously there's sometimes you can
see the ones that are like teenagers
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah to be
doing that yes exactly now let's come to
the solutions yeah and uh I want to ask
you as well since the question and I'm
going to come to a golden advice that I
want to give you guys here you guys are
all younger than me I want to give you
guys a golden advice I think which
really benefit you guys huh I'm 29. oh
is it okay okay yeah four years yeah
um so when you come across do you see
these things happening in your uni yeah
absolutely all the time you can get them
back closer please yeah so how do you
how do you deal with it so let's say you
come and you see a brother and sister in
that uh what's the attitude that your
friends have is it like let's go speak
to them or is it like everybody's doing
it or who cares
I mean if I see anything like that my
friends and I would just be like okay at
the end of the day it's bad but they're
gonna go in their own grave obviously
we're not gonna answer for them there's
a way of dealing with something like
your the way you speak to them either
like if you're advising them in a way
like you sit them down and you'll be
like obviously you're not gonna bash
them in the face that oh you were doing
this this is Haram there's a way of
dealing with it
so there's wisdom so it's it's about the
way you give it I'll be honest sometimes
you know what bro sometimes you just
write you know these cards that I made I
would just give it to my work off bro
and they let the car do the talking Rob
yeah just write it down write it down
and just give it yeah yeah just write
down because you know what they don't
know what it is they can read it they
can read it on their own time if they're
going to get mad you're not there for
them to get mad at you yeah by the time
you walked off anyway yeah yeah yeah you
have to work off yeah let me give you
guys no golden advice yeah um so we
talked about things for example what you
do Islamic school you said well how are
you going to stop them Etc yeah yeah
I want you guys to remember this yeah
okay a person I've like learned so much
on this it's not a concept like for
example in Islam
when we look at Iblis yeah okay and I
mentioned the story why did caitan I
believe Satan by the way is the head
yeah he he fell into disbelief yeah so
how did he fall into this belief Allah
told him to bow down to Adam okay what
did he use to say to God so God Almighty
told him that God Almighty created Adam
himself with his hands yeah the way with
his majesty and he told iblees Satan by
the way Satan was a very uh um good
individuals a righteous person he used
to worship God Almighty so he was not
what he's today the best of his time it
was the best of his kind and he had a
downfall what did he say to Allah he
said to Allah
yeah so he said to Adam he looked at
Adam and he was jealous of Adam so he
thought he should he deserved that kind
of um status so he said I am better than
him now when he said I am better than
him what did he use
he used his logic
over the knuckle the knuckle is what God
Almighty has told us to do which is the
Quran the stipulations yeah
when it comes to this stuff bro if
you're telling me this the the version
of a suit on in a Islamic school the the
question is this part yeah when people
when people when people send their kids
to UNI for Korea do you know what we're
doing this is what we're doing here and
this is why I believe Allah if we
understand and implement this concept be
for those in her own relationship be for
those who are in a career okay you are
going to University and thinking that
that degree is going to get you a job
and pay job and you're going to be happy
that's nonsense let me tell you it's
nonsense yeah let me tell you something
I know people who haven't got Union and
by the way I'm not saying those who go
uni they don't get it
I mean that's the second time you use it
but we can't use it anymore so that's
that's invalid avoid but you can touch
everyone after yeah so the thing isn't
that doesn't mean you don't go to UNI
but if you think that you going you need
to get career and this text you don't
know ask Allah what is good for you now
when it comes to the Haram relationships
it's the same thing you meet somebody in
uni and you think to yourself right
we're not ready to get married but I
like him I like her so you know what
let's have you know and it always starts
with good intentions we're going to get
married Satan never comes to you and
says hey go and have sex outside of
marriage yeah no he will come to you and
say some more steps your intentions are
good you guys it's marriage he's going
to come and give you slowly so what
happens is the sister or the brother
thinks you know what let's keep this
relationship going the next thing you
know it turns event invention into some
something that it shouldn't be why
because they're thinking if we cut you
off now oh but why if you marry someone
else why if she goes with someone else
what are we using to make those
judgments our logic now what we're
seeing is in Islam that our soul trust
means having trusted in black and white
it has to be with Allah
meaning sending your school to an
Islamic your child to an Islamic school
and thinking is not gonna prove if if
it's up if it's we have a trust in Allah
yeah important you can send them to the
most Islamic school that is fenced up
with security guards and lazy beams yeah
if they're going to go and smoke they're
gonna go and smoke so we have to have a
trust in who not our logical things that
we think he has uni and if we do this
and if we do it that's well and good you
should do that nobody's saying don't do
those stuff but if you have your
ultimate trust in these things bro Allah
will humiliate you and just to finish if
you have your ultimate trust in Allah
and do your bits bro you will be better
off with Haram relationships to Korea to
your whatever it may be
so the main thing is when it comes to
University now
I think going to University without a
game plan I would totally agree with you
bro
do you see what I'm saying it's an
absolute waste of time it's it's a waste
of energy and a waste of time
specifically energy now now positive
energy is is better yet labeled Synergy
basically and Synergy is a process of
what we're doing right now which is
we're getting together right now we're
doing something productive as a group
and we're trying to Captivate the
greater audience out there now now when
we think about you know going back to
University and staying on point now
inshallah is that I went to University
because I had to go to university for my
career as a paralegal you you cannot
become a solicitor without having a
degree not specifically a degree in law
I've done a degree in law it was
optional for me but you definitely do
need a degree and you need to do further
studies which is the sqe which is what
I'm currently on right now so it's a
select alarm about so it's a solicitors
qualifying exam insurance I'm looking to
you know sit in July and click the last
you know I need the job so okay so going
back to the main point now let's talk
about Solutions
so what are the solutions that you would
guys will give uh to those who are going
uni who are exposed to this kind of
stuff getting involved in her own
relationships
um Etc so what solutions would you guys
personally give if there's a young
person so I've seen so a lot of
universities unfortunately they're not
actually providing any type of
matchmaking services so that's the first
thing you know so if you're going to
University and you know you speak to
let's say I suck now I've been having a
few issues with them as well but yeah I
want to get into that in a minute but
yeah what's happening is right they're
kind of just like setting all these
barriers where oh it's up to guys and
girls to kind of just figure out you
know getting into the relationship and
stuff like that we can only we can only
you know do lectures and we can only you
know speak on Hawaiian relationships but
I've seen from a lot of Muslims here
I've come across a lot of people like to
talk you know I'm saying they're not
actually providing Solutions in it so
then that's the way it wasn't it so then
after once I finished University I kind
of saw that this was like a big big
problem because it was myself I went
through and I know I lot of my friends
as well close friends guys who've gone
to UNI they weren't able to find
somebody at University in the right way
as well a lot of the time so then I was
like okay cool let me actually create a
solution yeah and that's what I'm about
I've always been a type of person to you
know I'm saying look for you know a way
out where it's practical and that's why
I created you know the matchmaking
service Union students much so it's
essentially a matchmaking service you
can't send each other photos the any
sisters that sign up you need your
consent of your your Wally so God where
did you did you make mattress
matchmaking service yeah I've created
yeah yeah
so essentially you need the consent of
your your Wally and then phone number of
the Wally so then he's he's fully in the
process of that situation and he knows
what's going on and then on top of that
you know you I've got algorithms in
place to block any type of inappropriate
language as well so that's why I've
created in a way where unfortunately
universities are not providing Solutions
I create a solution which is a third
party so you can see me as a third party
essentially and then obviously people
can sign up as free well you know
hopefully you know I'm saying find
somebody on there get married have the
pet families involved and then that way
you can do it the right way you don't
need to do go to UNI and like try and do
this all yourself you can literally have
for example like if this doesn't have
your have your dad fully there and then
he's he's supporting you every step of
the way or like if you haven't got a dad
for example you could have for example a
trusted member of the Masjid or somebody
who's like you know what I'm saying he's
got a bit of level of authority and that
way he can help engage you guys
absolutely and when it comes back to
that function now I think that's the
main function when it the the sort of
Miriam and the non-meta aspect of it now
when it comes to Haram relationships the
main thing that we need that that get
that efficiently gets scrutinized for
becoming a Haram relationship is the
fact that they're talking without the
sisters basically within the same room
or within the same vicinity basically
now we've accommodated that on our
platform because we've seen that as a
major thing that obviously other
platforms like other competitive
platforms aren't really pushing out when
when we look at the number now and we
look at every single DM a brother would
send her sister that brought that um
uncle brother whoever it is he's getting
notified yeah every step of the way he's
getting every single message he's
vetting the message and it's up to him
whether he could say you know that uh
yeah no he seems okay he's a person
martial I'd like to get to know him I'd
like to invite him and the platform is
there to use it's used as a initiate
conversation essentially so to initiate
a conversation and after that you know
postices to meet one another and you can
exchange like obviously contact details
phone numbers on you know the platform
so in that way you can you know vet a
person in real life because that's where
you is the whole golden objective is to
get people to you know bring their
families together okay and I think a lot
of times nowadays in relationships
people ain't bringing their families you
know I'm saying that's and that's the
problem because they've got a lot more
experience than us they've got a lot
more issues when it comes to marriages
they've got experience when it comes to
children when it comes to essentially
you know exactly like a lot more years
of life so if guys been here for like 40
50 60 years he's been on this Earth yeah
he's gonna have a lot more knowledge and
wisdom likely anyway on relationships
well that's what that's what they said
provide that oh that's what they suffer
but forget like your parents you should
be your parents as well but you know
Alana's Mission has made things very
clear and if you know you're going to
suffer that makes it very categorical
okay well like you you are going to
suffer and heartbreak is one of the pain
very painful stuff trust me your sister
yeah can I just say something about the
app so
um my cousin just came to visit like a
couple months ago for only one week for
Morocco and her sister told her
mismatch to see like and the first the
first guy came up Allah he's a good guy
um
he came to the house
alhamdulillah everything's good the
signed the papers like one week less
than one week
and now she's in Morocco she's gonna
have her wedding there her husband's um
sorry Pakistanian yeah
he's a good guy I love his family his
mom his dad like the app masha'allah is
very good I'll give you credit for that
yeah okay so if I'm mistaken you just
mention most much yeah okay so so okay
so no no I've created in a way where
essentially you know okay you can't you
can't essentially once again
no no but obviously some people that's
what I'm saying yeah yeah I'm trying to
understand like
that their app is different there by the
way yeah yeah I think it's mismatch yeah
the reason I'm saying is there's good
and bad to that yeah so I'm gonna I'm
gonna beat the name out for uh reasons
but those success stories do happen they
do happen yeah because I was gonna say
that essentially a lot of times you know
if you look at the the studies of you
know like Tinder and you know all the
dating apps in general they tend to you
know if you look at the actual swipe
right but we swipe wipe and swipe left
here yeah it's around 90 of guys they're
getting basically you know swipe left
when it comes to girls yeah go to
swiping five five five five percent less
than that yeah and it's usually the same
type of guys that they're usually
swiping for yeah and then other way is
like around 45 50 yes yeah so when it
comes to when it comes to guys so it
just shows guys are liking more than the
woman so it's just skewed in it so I've
created I've limited today so I've made
it an equal platform where it's an equal
opportunity for everyone so everyone's
got fair share do you understand you're
not getting charged based off your photo
you're not getting judged based off or
you know whatever experience you've had
you've got essentially achieve an
opportunity where you create a profile
for yourself once you create a profile
and then you can mention under your
streams weaknesses this this and that
okay and then that way they're you okay
no problem bless you guys for giving the
solution at least you know you know
those who criticize that they stay at
home don't do nothing and those who want
to take action because a lot of the guys
what they've done is they allowed to
talk in it but when it comes to actual
practicality and create Solutions yeah
they don't want to do that yeah they'll
have to be like oh yes sorry no we
rather leave the brothers yeah yeah I
was like okay that's fine if you don't
want it man if you get them you can
provide you can why don't you provide
some type of you know paid service
pay service for brothers and sisters we
want to do it the right way exactly and
you haven't even given that so if you
haven't even given it would you expect
that's why you see Zena problems in the
University yeah that's why it's the
situation we have today yeah they're not
doing their bit you know what I'm saying
they're not doing that yeah that's why I
know the fingers that's why I suppose I
support what you guys are doing because
at the end of the day I look for
Solutions what I'm trying to say the
reason I started the reason I started
the bitter trip show is because one of
the biggest Fitness that we're facing
trials is divorce is divorce not looking
it's and that's MP
to our society is divorces people
getting divorced we're going to wrap up
starting from Sister Aisha and then
sister your name
[Music]
can we just maybe give some solutions to
those young girls who are going to
University what should they be careful
to and maybe they want to see it to them
and they will wrap up
just okay I'm gonna say if you need to
get close to them if you're gonna go uni
just go uni I know like you're gonna get
tempted to do other things but it's like
the people you hang around with have the
most influence on you so if you think
that someone's influencing you in a bad
way just cut them off it's not worth it
100 I agree
um who you hang around with is a
reflection on you so you have to really
decide when you're while you're at Uni
what it is you want do you want to live
a life understand or do you want to
leave live clean and the other thing is
remember there's a whole You've got a
whole life ahead of you yeah what are
you at not 18 19 in University when you
first start at the end of the day you've
got plenty of time to be messing around
right now studying study get your life
in order you know everything else will
come don't rush into things because when
you rush into things this is why you get
big high rates of divorce because you
get married too quickly you get married
at the wrong time you're too young or
you don't really understand what love
really is what relationships really are
so take your time first and prior
prioritize the you know more important
things in life a relationship will come
you'll get married you'll do what you
got to do but right now focus on your
studies focus on important things
because that's where you will that's
what's going to take you far in life
100 I would say go uni for you because
you're studying for you you're not
studying for someone else so just focus
on yourself Allah and make your mom your
whole family proud
you should feel proud yourself for love
like
yeah this I would say if you want to get
married just go to your mom say Mom Dad
I like this guy he seems very nice can
you um
talk to him obviously and get like a
background check and that's it you don't
need to do it around do the right way
like sisters out there do the right way
like
so guys uh check out uni student match
inshallah which they found a solution
for those who are going uni and
bachelor's
um
so and so inshallah you guys can sign up
to that it's a solution and like I said
before guys uh put your Dean first put
Allah and your religion first uh that's
what's going to happen you know before
you graduate you might be on the day of
judgment and their judgment will be a
day of graduation those who believe who
do righteous Deeds it's a day of
graduation so focus on the actual
graduation because we put so much effort
and emphasis on like my graduation day I
need to study all this kind of stuff
here and some people do it at the cost
of not even praying they don't even fast
because they're in her own relationships
and can you imagine you yeah it's you're
going to UNI let that uni be for the
sake of Allah
um and you know yes you know the point
is just in a nutshell prioritize your
religion and for sisters uh like I said
before
um I believe you guys um the
repercussions are greater for you guys
so I would say look you guys a woman can
be uh they are emotional by the nature I
know some feminists don't like that but
I'll just be quiet yeah it's proven
exactly you know the bad thing exactly
but it's not about you know sadly we
didn't have some toxic families here so
the things
is never going to be the same yeah men
are visual creatures they fall for what
they see women are emotional beings they
fall for what they hear so my dear
sisters protect yourself inshallah and
may also preserve you and the one that's
written for you will be there yes it
might not be the person you in a Haram
relationship with and the same goes with
brothers
and honor your sisters whoever it may be
would you want somebody moving to your
sister trying to interrupt your sister
or your mom yes your mom your sister
whoever may be inshallah so that's it
from a bit of Truth me all of this you
guys
um there will be a code ensure that you
guys can check inshallah and sign up to
UNI student match till next time
brothers and sisters
from this episode
don't miss basic opportunity from
Nature's blends to get your finest
premium black seed oil and shilajit to
get that energy levels back up check
them out now